ريسي سوناك في اول خطاب رئيسي له يكشف من
خلاله عن اولويات حكومته في مواجهه
التحديات البلاد خفض التضخم على راسي
وعودي لشعبي لتحسين معيشته وخدماته ولمنحه
الامن المالي
لدينا خمسه وعود تخفيض التضخم الى النصف
تنميه الاقتصاد واخفض الديون وقوائم
الانتظار في الصحه ووقف القوارب تلك هي
اولويات الشعب انها اولويات حكومتكم
خطاب سناك ياتي في وقت يعاني فيه ملايين
البريطانيين من غلاء المعيشه وترد الخدمات
العامه ولاسيما في القطاع
الصحيحه لزياده عدد الاسره بمقدار سبعه
الاف سرير في المستشفيات ومن يتلقون
الرعايه في المنزل
شرطه وتدريس التلاميذ الرياضيات حتى سن
الثامنه عشر وختم هناك خطابه بالتاكيد على
ان اولويات المواطنين هي اولويات حكومته
ويؤكد العزمه على اعاده الثقه في السياسه
هناك يدعو الناخبين لبناء احكامهم على
فتره ولايته انطلاقا من تعهداته وقدرته
على الوفاء بها بالرغم من التحديات التي
تواجه قبل عامين من الانتخابات العامه
مصطفى زاروه العربيه لندن